thank you so much for being here so much
to talk about first of all I went and
saw a young friend of sign in Seattle
with my wife wise we loved the show big
hit and just voted best Broadway show by
Entertainment Weekly readers which is my
favorite Broadway show the Year by you
are you having fun doing it it looks
like you're having a blast it's so much
fun to do um what's the hardest thing
about I've never done that kind of show
yeah with professional quality stuff
going on there seemed to be rehearsals
and precision and adults enjoy it ow
what is it what's the hardest thing
about doing a show like that night after
night after night putting on the
pantyhose number one harness yeah and
the second hardest thing is I have to
tape my boobs into the costumes because
otherwise they tend to like fly out at
inopportune moments their own if you're
if you're moving around or just on your
own they fly out everybody wants to be a
tape them in and then at the end of the
night I have to like rip them out and
and then I'll have like sort of brown
tape residue on my boobs which is that's
just brown tape residue yeah it's one
time years ago I was doing a musical at
the Pasadena Playhouse and it was set in
the 20s and so there was a big this was
back in the day when I was quite the
terpsichorean terror and there was a big
dancer meet the dancer I went to an
altered state for a moment I was doing
this big dance number at the end of Act
one that was sort of a Charleston and it
was very peppy and the audience was all
looking at me with big smiles on their
faces they're pointing at me and the
gleeful expressions and I got offstage
and I realized both of my boobs have
been Lilly literally resting on top
they paid extra that night I thought now
I know that you you had a birthday since
Young Frankenstein open what did you do
to celebrate you know oh the show is in
Times Square and we are located directly
next door to a strip club only the
finest fermion Conan champagne wishes
and caviar dreams and which strictly is
this
cheetahs cheetahs okay yeah that's a
good one you been there I know I haven't
offered to be insulted by that
you're such a man so much that it's like
Hello Dolly when you come in and they
carry you on a litter or through the
break this way mr. O Brien your favorite
drink is ready we'll bring candy right
over and no doesn't happen so they the
cast of the show who took me to cheat us
for my birthday and we got there and I
was kind of nervous because I didn't
know like do you walk in and there's
just naked girls but no you walk in it's
actually a restaurant which i think is
odd first their first room is a
restaurant and at the restaurant they're
serving sushi mm-hmm does that seem odd
to you yeah you know I'm particularly
you always think you want sushi from
just the highest quality condoning me
and it's just like at the strip club you
want some raw fish
my writers are so proud to not be here
[Applause]
yeah it seems like an unfortunate choice
to me but anyway so we're standing there
and there was sort of like a bed a table
in the middle of the room and this girl
comes in takes off her robe lays down on
the table naked see a little g-string on
and the guy comes out and puts the sushi
down on her body lays the sushi oh
you're supposed to eat the sushi off of
the naked girl what really yes but is it
is it I mean is that she he didn't make
me hungry and it doesn't seem sexy
tonight either one so um I didn't really
I had strangely lost my appetite at that
point and then one of the girls the cast
comes over and she's like you'll get in
there eat that sushi did you want to
hurt her feelings
right so you you're a beautiful skin so
we get it we cuticle skin fine
cheekbones chopsticks that you're eating
sushi sushi with chopsticks off of this
naked woman and there's like there's
like soy sauce I mean it's crazy so
you're like dipping it in a bowl like
you know like happy birthday so that I'm
thinking oh this is so depressing this
is not a strip clubs about
you know oh well it was already so
depressing I thought what do you do next
year make a snuff film I mean this feels
great
Wow
it was awful so then we have to go into
the room with the like naked people so
it was just the whole our group was all
gay guys and straight women strangely
enough and we go in and I think what a
waste of time for everybody for you guys
for the girls there it's just no one's
happy in this situation because of that
it took on this strangely kind of fun
like wholesome all-american quality of
like a sort of like a church social gone
terribly wrong question if it's straight
women and gay men why not go to a male
strip club I personally don't want some
guys big package waggling around my face
I mean I call me crazy I'm not it's not
my thought with you on that I was just
stunned by the image you know I we're
almost out of time but I know you did
want to say something this is important
yes well you know the strike is going on
and I just wanted to say that I am with
Conan and I share your views completely
I side with the writers and I think that
every person who works is entitled to
their fair share and and the right I
mean just in your career the writing on
will embrace that wouldn't just suppose
to know that I would be sitting here if
it weren't for the character of Karen
Walker which I didn't make up that our
brilliant writers on that show right
made that up so and also I wanted to say
that in solidarity solidarity I too will
not be shaving until the stripers
yeah yeah I'm Frankenstein I love
there's no transition there I'm gonna be
so honest I'm just a young Frankenstein
is now playing at the Hilton Theater in
New York City the latest CD from
Meghan's band Megan Mullally and supreme
music program is available on iTunes so
go and get that and you're one of the
most talented people I know thanks for
being here Megan Mullally
[Applause]